[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money we're going to talk about
right in front of you baby open phones
at
5225 the call is free and some say it's
worth exactly what you pay for it Kim is
with us Kim is in Asheville North
Carolina starting off this hour hi Kim
how are you hello how are you better
than I deserve what's
up okay so I have a question um we hired
a gentleman to do our taxes in March of
this year and we ended up hiring him to
do financial planning for us as well and
after hiring him to do that we
discovered that he had filed bankruptcy
twice and had been sued for writing a
bad
check and so my question is um well he F
bankruptcy in 2019 was his last one that
was the second one and the it said the
certified financial planning board
revoked his right to use their
certification marks H and then he also
was sued for writing a bad check to a
moving company recently
and that was um in
2018 and
so we had already paid him a large fee
to use him for financial planning and I
guess my question is should this be of
concern to
us we have discussed this with him what
did he say he says that we don't
understand what it's like to run our own
business um and just basically was you
know he was very rude about it and said
his business would go on with or without
us oh uh I want money back am leaving I
don't care about the bankruptcy with
your butt I don't want to work with
you right and he you don't get to be
rude to me about this you're you're self
you're defensive which means that
yeah I've been I've been sued and I
filed bankruptcy but if you ask me about
it I'll just tell you I almost feel like
you not last week but I mean I'll just
tell you right I almost feel like you
open with that if you're if that's part
of your story that's what's informed you
to this point he claimed that he told us
in the contract well I made him send
that back to us because it disappeared
after we signed it and we couldn't see
our own copy so he sent it to me a
couple weeks ago there was a link that
we could click in small print about this
how you pay this guy
$1,500 okay will he refund you or not he
will not okay I'm walking anyway I'm
walking anyway I'm walking anyway well
yeah we told him we were walking because
we don't trust him and just because of
his attitude exactly exactly it's not
the thing it's the attitude okay because
here's the thing okay let's say the
moving company tore up 17 of his items
and then they would then they wanted to
you know and then he unpacked it and
found a vase that they were responsible
for they don't want to refund him for
the broken vase so he stops payment on
the check they sue him well that's a
valid story sure right he also he told
me that he didn't he settled that check
I said well you didn't settle it or they
wouldn't have sued you yeah and well
it's the attitude is the thing it's like
look hey if I were in your here's the
proper way to answer this question if
I'm him if I were in your shoes I'd have
these exact same concerns I'm happy to
tell you the details okay here's what
happened in this situation and here's
what happened in that situation and the
bankruptcy was not you don't understand
why it's like to run a business the
bankruptcy was I did some stupid butt
things I learned from it and I'm not
doing them anymore the check was the
moving company misbehaved and I used
that as leverage and it got out of hand
and they sued me but they had no basis
to judge through it out yeah he blamed
his ex-wife for the bad check I I don't
care you see what I'm saying that if you
had gone that way then he would have
redeemed his credibility if he had been
smarter and done what Jade said and set
upfront what was going on it's part of
your story that's fine that's fine
that's what we felt but I've been sued
for things that I didn't do that they
made up in an effort to try to basically
use the court system to Blackmail me to
settle with them I refused to settle
with them so that gets all in the news
so you can look up Dave Ramsey got sued
but the basis of the lawsuits are zero
didn't absolutely did not occur but it
doesn't matter you can sue somebody for
anything in America so I don't mind
telling you that that's happened okay um
but I but I still got you know I've
still got if you want to be pissed at
Dave Ramsey randomly you can find places
on the internet that I did all kinds of
things I didn't
do yeah well I you know he said he was
going to sue the certified financial
planning board for good luck with that
yeah and I was like how can you do that
yeah he just sounds a little I don't I
really don't like his attitude I don't
like that he's defensive he sounds like
he's pointing the finger blaming it
doesn't sound like it's going to be a
fun work environment for you to work
with this gu I'm walking away I think I
think I think you should walk away and
you already had walked away so you
already knew the answer to the question
yeah she did well she probably wanted to
know if there was some way she could
force him to get the money back but I
wouldn't put any effort into it I'd just
move on I don't think you're going to
turn him into not being a jerk yeah I
think he's already got that one down
well if he hasn't done any work for them
yet in that capacity I feel like a good
person would say hey you didn't know
this we haven't started this yet here's
your money back even a not good person
knows that some customers are worth more
are more trouble than they're worth and
if I'm her and I disagree with her I
mean if I'm him and I disag with her
she's more trouble than she's worth
there's your money back yeah go away
even if I even even if I'm not a good
person it's just it's worth the just to
get rid of them absolutely you know we
fire a customer around here that
misbehaves ever so often they you can't
call here and cuss at our people we
don't allow you to do that we'll give
you your money back tell you go away you
know that's all right I don't I don't
put up with your junk cuz some customer
service uh people in America their whole
job is to get cussed at by Rah holic all
day long ter and we don't our our
customer service people I tell them
listen tell them no yeah we don't wait a
minute wait we don't talk like that here
you're not doing that just call
somewhere else and be pissed off take
your money and that you're going to use
here and use it for counseling you need
it you know just move on right but yeah
I mean it it's even if you're on the
other side of it it's worth it to get
rid of and I don't think Kim's that I
think Kim's figured this out um yeah the
sad thing is is that now she's
questioning all Financial people or
planners yeah whether trth I'll tell you
what you know smart Vester Pro will sit
down with you they don't charge you a
thing cuz they make a commission yep off
of uh selling you a mutual fund for your
for your Roth IRA or your kids college
fund um and they don't make anything
unless they sell you something so people
are all suspect about that but they're
the good ones they do it with the heart
of a teacher that's why we endorse smart
investor Pros uh we don't have any fee
based financial planners in our system
yeah that are upfront
fees uh not because I'm mad at them they
just don't like
us because I endorse mutual funds yeah
that makesense and um you
know because here's the thing there's a
thing in the financial world is worth
talking about this in the 20 seconds
we've got called the fiduciary and you
see it there's there's one company
running and they're lying about it on
their TV ad during uh football I saw it
last two or three weekends I can't think
what it's called little green sign in
the background but like we are
fiduciaries we are fiduciaries we don't
make anything unless you make something
we are fidu no the word fiduciary means
a person of trust can you trust someone
that gets a commission yes if they're
trustworthy all real estate agents are
commission-based fiduciaries and they
should put your interest first yeah they
just they but just because you get paid
when they make a sale doesn't mean you
can't have integrity that's right that's
absurd so that's the financial world
right now this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host to today the Ramsey Show
question of the day sponsored by
neighborly your hub for home services
from repairs and maintenance to
Remodeling and upgrades neighborly
trusted home service providers have
trained local experts to handle almost
any job download the neighborly app and
you can connect to all the help you need
these are great people they are today's
question of the day comes from Paula in
Georgia my son's school is running a
food bank so I sent him with some highly
requested items such as peanut butter
canned soup and tuna fish when my
husband saw them he insisted we don't
donate quality items like these and
instead only Donate rice and beans I'm
aware that you've told people to eat
beans and rice if they're on a tight
budget and cannot afford to indulge in
nicer Foods however I also know that you
value generosity and giving and I didn't
see anything wrong with donating
something other than beans and rice do
you believe that the same principle
applied to those on a tight budget
should also be applied to recipients of
food
banks oh brother I don't mean to laugh
but it's just so silly that's silly it's
silly yeah number one when we say beans
and rice honey it's a metaphor yeah a
metaphor is a a representation
philosophically of an actual item I am
not suggesting that people only live on
beans and rice I am suggesting that you
quit spinning s dad gun much money on
food especially eating out all the time
so probably prime rib is not on your
list lobster tail but possibly even some
Hamburger Helper might make the list you
don't have to just literally do beans
and rice it's a metaphor I think this
guy was just looking for an excuse to be
a tight wad be a che he didn't have to
look for an excuse he already was I mean
goodness gracious and it's not like tuna
fish is that big of an upgrade from
riceing Beans I mean come on now and
here's the deal I mean what we're
talking about is you limiting your
consumption so you can create margin
yeah to move ahead we're not talking
about those poor people don't need any
good food what in the world dude ter
seriously seriously yeah that's horrible
yes they need some good food send them
some good food you cheap skate your wife
is right your son is even better learn
from them sir yeah oh my gosh if you're
going to give something away be generous
with what you're giving that's right H
I'm going to give you a c but it doesn't
really run because you can just you can
figure that out for yourself what in the
world you know what Dave though I I've
I've been okay so I've been here about
13 months 14 months I am shocked at how
many people I've encountered that think
they're beans and rice rice and beans
thing is literal let me tell you what's
worse okay 30 years of doing this I have
had precisely
4732 offers to co-author a beans and
rice cookbook with other listeners
I made that up but it's close to 4,000 I
mean it's unbelievable the and
apparently it would be a best seller if
we could just get the people that wanted
to co-author it look with me to buy it
but yeah people keep asking me about it
beans and rice cookbook no it's it's a
it's a metaphor a metaphor it's a
metaphor yes you can this you can eat
different food look it up look up
metaphor it's good oh my gosh yeah but
we don't need to be going out to eat
every night it's some fancy spancy thing
or for that for fast food yeah because
it's fast but it's not necessarily food
and the
um and you know you're working so that
you can learn to put yourself as a guy I
used to work for would say we're working
so I can get enough money that I can
read the menu from left to right I know
that's right I don't start with the
price I get to start with a thing and
pick what I want prices irrelevant but
when you're broke you
self-manage your consumption not other
people imposing on you yeah their their
beans and rice so oh my gosh yeah then
you're entering into like a judgment
kind of Zone I think and it's like well
just be generous if you can yeah I mean
I yeah you you kind of missed the point
sir yeah you kind of not kind of you did
all right Ali is with us aa's in
Washington DC hi Aya what's up hi Mr
Ramsey hey um I was wondering if we
should pay off our current mortgage and
relocate for a current cheaper
mortgage what's making you ask that
question wait pay off your current
mortgage a or
relocate and get a cheaper mortgage what
would be cheaper than a paid off
mortgage um so we bought a house that
needed to be fixed up so we fixed it up
and now it's we just had a realer come
out and tell us what we could list it as
my husband was in the military and just
got out and his job fell through so it
kind of shook us and we just wanted to
move somewhere with the proceeds to have
a cheap enough mortgage to be covered by
my
disability okay um so you're not you
don't have the opportunity to pay off
your mortgage you're talking about
moving to a less expensive property
because you're scared about his
income right why do you think he's not
going to get an
income um it's not so much that he
wouldn't get one we're just um kind of
thinking about repr prioritizing our
time the house that we bought is a
historic house so it takes a lot of
Maintenance we do a lot of the work
ourselves that's a different discussion
what do you owe on that
house uh $490 490,000 I already don't
like the house I hate that we have spent
so much time on it we can get some good
money for it and get something I like is
a good reasonable move I'm using his
lack of a job and a cheaper mortgage as
my excuse is not
okay okay um you see the difference
we're just kind of we're both yeah we're
both on the same boat so we're just you
know the boat where he doesn't
work just that he has more
flexibility and we're
not how old is he not right now how old
is he we're 25 and 26 okay he needs to
get a career
darling it's not good for him to not
work much I'm not saying he won't work I
am saying he needs to get a career where
he
works okay I'm hearing the code words in
your language 100% he's not wanting to
work much at all and that's worrying
part of it is he got knocked out of the
saddle and didn't get the other job and
it's he's lost some of his confidence
and you're clearly worried because
you're talking about selling your house
and relocating so that you could only
live on your disability like you said it
with your own
words I don't think that that came out
right we he wants to work that's not the
issue the issue is is that we want to be
more flexible with not having to deal
with the house and not having a mortgage
that's so high is the mortgage more than
5% of your take-home pay it is now that
he's not working but before that was it
no it wasn't no it wasn't okay okay so
your mortgage amount is not your problem
the house if you want to get rid of a
house that's a money pit where you work
on it all the time I don't blame you I
would do that okay but let let's not
couch that in he wants more flexibility
and when I'm talking about his job your
answer is he wants more flexibility it
wasn't when I was talking about the
house repairs you said that so I didn't
I didn't miss understand you you said it
real clearly so what what we need to do
let's let's let's parse this out and
break it up number one the two of you
need to get really good cool strong
careers that you're passionate about I
will send you a copy of Ken Coleman's
book from paycheck to purpose number two
it doesn't sound like your mortgage is
off me neither and I'm I'm actually
wondering number three I would sell a
house that's a money pit and I had to
screw with it all the time it drive me
nuts that's true but I don't know that
if it's a money pit that's one thing but
I don't know I'd be interested in know
more she's in Washington DC where does
she plan on
relocating where she's going to they may
be move to a whole different city too
that's possible but yeah which would be
less expensive for sure yeah I'm getting
rid of The Money Pit but I'm also
getting a career yeah they need and
probably getting a house about the same
price range that in The Money Pit M when
to make the move that's would be my
advice to you guys don't don't mix these
things together and create some kind of
false narrative that's not really going
on okay that's what I heard you say
saying I think you were saying it
whether you wanted to or not this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
in the lobby of ramsy Solutions on the
debt free stage Christina is with us hi
Christina how are you hi good welcome
nervous oh yeah you're okay we've never
lost a patient that's right you're going
to be all right we're proud of you so
you're here to do a debt-free scream
where do you live Clarksville Tennessee
Clarksville military family um I used to
be in the military but I'm not now okay
well thank you for serving a lot of lot
of military in Clarks that's what I was
asking yes all right and uh how much
debt did Christina from Clarksville pay
off $ 34,1 162 you're amazing how long
did this take 36 months good for you
th000 bucks a month get it and your
range of income during that three years
$4,490 a year to $
what do you do for a living um I have a
house cleaning business in Clarksville
ah did you start at 15,000 on your house
cleaning business well
so um my business started eight years
ago um but um my journey um officially
started I went through my first FPU
class in 2012 so I've been doing this
for a long time um I was married at the
time and
we tried to get on the same page and and
um couldn't couldn't and it took a lot
of years to figure out that we couldn't
so in 2020 of uh April of 2020 my
divorce was filed oh my gosh what a year
yeah and the next month my business
closed because you know nobody wants us
in our home when everybody has Co that's
right oh wow so I started off my journey
um in the basement of a friend of a
friend's house with not much money and
uh not really sure what was going to
happen and so since then um started
cleaning houses again yeah started clean
and the nice thing about Co is everybody
wanted their houses clean once we got
that started to going again so so we uh
we actually got got that back up and
going and now um now you're making 50
Grand that's a killer well well that's
everything included that's that's um
child support and everything but it it
that's quite a journey yeah good for you
you get after it girl way to go
incredible you got to feel like your
your whole life has transformed in 36
months yeah it has it's a whole
different world yeah I mean career
marital status
confidence everything wow oh and you got
out of debt I got out of debt yeah
you're amazing I'm so proud of you it's
it's not me it's all it's all God yeah
well he he was actually using you to
clean those toilets I know that's right
you you put you put in the work I did do
that
yeah you got to plant that corner it
doesn't grow as you so soal you reap way
to go kiddo very proud of you excellent
all right so uh what kind of debt was
$34,000 oh it was everything it was uh
it was back taxes it was uh back rent um
just from after the divorce it was um
student loan car loan um how' you CR all
the you got all the de debt from the
divorce um no I got a I got a little
just just over half of it uh but that
was my half half of everything okay so
the back rent was both of you and then
you got half the back rent mm okay I
love the support I'm seeing from your
son that that is that's hitting me man I
love it you you definitely clearly had
the support of your family next to you I
do that's the only reason that I got
here is because of all the support uh
it's one thing to have two teenagers
it's another to have two good ones I
mean yes wait what yeah where did it go
she's like what me yes
you amazing amazing wow well you know
they they've been with me the whole time
I mean right after right after um um
when we started cleaning again and and
things were starting to move along I
actually tried to homeschool them cuz
that was smart on top of everything I
had to deal with I thought that
homeschooling them was going to be a
good plan so for that first year after
coid we homeschooled for a year and and
and every month every month for um our
finance lesson I bought the The ramsy
Homeschool thing and everything and
every month for our we came up here we
came up here to watch your show uh and I
brought my planner and I would do my
budget at the end of the month right
here in the lobby and then whoever was
doing the show I had sign sign my
planner for that month so yall were kind
of my accountability for that first
month while I was trying to get back on
my feet wow wow you're my accountability
C when keep coming to work you're
inspiring very inspiring so they've been
with me they they've come along with me
on everything this year when when I
finally got in a head space to where I
could really buckle down um we I brought
them to the Building Wealth live um I
came to the smart conference I brought
them with me to meet micro for the labor
crisis so they've been drug along with
like everything so wow they're my little
buddies I love it I love it so what's
next building up the emergency fund
feeling good about the future how does
it feel to have no
debt surreal I mean I've been trying
since 2012 and and I just i' I listen to
these all the time I've come see I've
come seen your shows I mean for years
and I I cry every time that I I watch
one and I just never imagined I actually
be up here okay so you overcome living
in a friend of a friend's basement you
overcome the business closing down and
opening up you overcome $34,000 wor a
debt you overcome the loss of your
marriage all in the last 36 months you
truly are a warrior princess you're
amazing I mean that's powerful it really
is I feel like a lot of it was I don't
think it was because of me I think it
iel like most time it was in spite of me
cuz no you're a hero you're a hero you
need to own it yeah you do you committed
to for some people it really is a longer
journey and you committed for the whole
journey it's just like your shirt
anybody who can't read her shirt
everything is possible for the one who
believes and that is such I mean you're
really evidence of that you kept belief
and you kept going and you got knocked
down and you kept going and you got
knocked down again and you kept going
and here you are on the stage yeah but
I'm hard-headed too I actually called in
Ken show about six years ago to ask if I
should try to pay off debt or hire some
people for my business and he said that
you get what you focus on so I should
pay off debt so I went and I hired a
bunch of people
and that's
hilarious so so you know and then and
then I remember I remember um I remember
the back when y'all were in your old
building uh I got I I really I was I got
my husband got me my ex-husband got me a
a car for in 2018 for my birthday and I
had a paid off Van and I was listening
to I listen to you guys in a Fred Hall I
got all your books and I I've been
trying for a long time you know and uh I
got that and and part of me was like you
can't take this and then part of me was
like well it was a gift and her marriage
wasn't doing well so this is kind of fun
so well we'll see I felt so guilty
taking that car that the next day I
drove out to your old place in
brenwood to get a lecture from you on
why I shouldn't have a car payment and I
felt so I felt but I left I left the
office that morning and Nicole my office
manager she said so you going to tell
Dave that uh you're you're you're there
in your new car and I said absolutely
not and I said in fact I was so ashamed
that I parked across the street at the
stores and I walked over so that I
didn't have to park in your parking lot
wow you didn't defile the parking lot I
did not defile the parking lot and I I
cannot tell you when I got here this
morning and I was driving out here and
my my my financial coach Andy he took a
picture of my parking spot where you
have the name of all the Deb free
screams and like it like just kind of
blew me away like 5 years ago I was
hiding in the bushes and now you have
now you have a parking spot of Honor
look at that you don't have to park
across the street at the store in the
parking spot of Shame that's right
that's right I have a car that you can't
open the door from the outside but
that's okay that's only temporary that's
only temporary hey how old how old are
your your kiddos
um 16 and 14 16 and 14 and their names
uh his is grayon and Christian Grace and
Christian well go well done mom well
done I know you're nervous but um we're
pretty impressed you you we run into a
lot of people on this stage and some of
them are Overcomers some of them knock a
few things down uh you you you just took
a machete and whacked your way through
the jungle kiddo pretty amazing pretty
amazing well done hey we've got the live
and give box for you that includes The
Total Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
Millionaire's book cuz that's your
destiny and no stopping this one woo and
Financial Peace University membership
and you guys are incredible uh graceon
Christian I I know you know this but uh
your mom is a superhero very cool all
right count it down you guys 34,000 paid
off in 36 months from 15,000 to 49 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're Deb
free
wow goodness woo
allergies are bad this season I'm just
saying that'll make your eyes water
right there this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need need the
Churchill Mortgage home buyer Edge super
fast pre-approval and a secured interest
rate plus a $5,000 seller guarantee
gives your offer the best chance of
being accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 well in case you wondered if
smart cont conference that you did on
the hill up here was important last
caller told us it was or one of the
other streaming events or one of the
other 9 million things we do around here
like I'm doing a show every day and you
can come in here and watch the show live
is important we had no idea she'd been
in here all those times that's right it
first time we ever met her mhm so very
very interesting stuff very interesting
stuff speaking of starting your journey
uh Jade washaw will be doing a free
every dooll webinar at everydollar.com /
budgeting you can sign up and help you
break the cycle of living paycheck to
paycheck when is the webinar tomorrow
tomorrow at 11:30 central time so sign
up so like Tuesday the 10th yep Tuesday
the 10th the 10th at 11:30 a.m. Central
Time if you're not able to do that or
you hear this at a later date because
you can catch it on your podcast or
YouTube or something at a later date
there are others so be sure to go to
everydollar.com budgeting Jade will be
doing more Rachel Cruz will be doing
more and George will be doing more of
these uh budgeting webinars and they
actually make budgeting fun they
actually help you work out how to take
your paychecks and pick out which thing
goes in which thing we call it paycheck
planning through the month so every
dollar has an assignment for that matter
every dollar of every check has an
assignment when you're done uh it's a
very usable very friendly world's best
budgeting app and by the way we're not
charging you this free totally free
every doll webinar everydollar.com
budgeting sign up and jump in all right
Jennifer is with us Jennifer is in
Colorado Springs hi Jennifer how are you
I'm good how about yourself better than
I deserve what's
up well I'm brand new to um home
ownership um and unfortunately my
husband and I bought this house together
two months before he passed so now I'm
kind of stuck in in a ridiculous Place
overwhelmed and unexpected what happened
to it two months ago or when no he
passed in June but we he passed two
months after we bought the house W I'm
so sorry how old was he 53 oh I'm sorry
young what happened yeah um well long
story short end stage liver failure oh
oh my I'm so sorry well how long were
youall married um 14 years okay how old
and you're about the same age I'm 47 47
okay all right how can we help today I'm
so sorry so thank you so anyway like I
said this is the first home I've ever
owned and I'm trying to figure out
everything on my own and it just so
happened that the neighbor that we share
a fence line with and there is just one
fence line the fence line fell into my
property and I was hoping that the
homeowner adjacent would go half and
half on replacing the fence but they
don't seem interested in that so I guess
I'm stuck with fixing the fence by
myself okay um well typically the fence
is put up just inside the property line
of one party or the other okay so if the
survey was done the fence posts would
typically be on your property or on
their property meaning that it's either
your fence or their
fence okay the posts were definitely on
their property okay so it's definitely
their fence fix I guess so now that you
explained it yeah yeah and so um you
know now uh did something knock it down
or it just rotted down or what just yeah
just rotted and it was the wind but we
both have dogs so I feel somewhat
responsible to get it fixed as opposed
to what you know it just being an issue
you know so I just didn't know what the
recourse if there is any or if I just
need to fix it because they won't did
when you brought it to them they were
probably unaware of whose property it
was on do you think that if you let them
know hey it's on your property do you
think that would change it at all or is
it just a situation where they're not
spending money on that yeah I can try
now that you told me that because I
wasn't sure you know I just didn't know
so if I if I the fence poster on your
property so this is your fence I will go
in with you to help you fix your
fence oh you know what that sounds a lot
Kinder but I sent can we split this
that's a different
if cuz they're going to be the owner of
the fence when it's fixed M and you're
just doing that out of the goodness of
you're doing that to keep your dogs out
of their yard absolutely and their dogs
out of mine but I didn't know that and I
wasn't armed with that so maybe I'll try
that and see what happens I appreciate
it yeah I don't know my guess is they
don't have the money yeah so none of
this might change it it might also might
help to this is what I would do I might
have someone come look at it so I had
some actual numbers to say hey oh sure I
was looking at this if we both chip in
you know $600 I don't know what that
cost if we both chip in $600 they'll
come out and fix it the I know you know
and tell them it's on their side hey I I
took I looked at the parameters it's
technically your fence but it benefits
both of us if you chip in 600 I'll chip
in 600 you know I already found a guy
will fix your fans yeah that sounds
reasonable I like that think you very
much I didn't even think about that yeah
how how how big a piece of property are
we dealing with
how long how long how many how many how
long is the section of fences down 50
feet 500 guess it's like I don't know
it's like eight panels so I I'm not
really good at that okay so it's like a
privacy
fence correct yes okay all right well
we're not talking a lot of money here
then well that's good I was just didn't
know if I had any recourse to action but
I like what you said I don't think you
have any
recourse I think you've got persuasion
and neighborly love and those kinds of
things because here's the problem if you
put up a fence just inside your property
they can attach to it and still get the
benefit of it exactly but you know and
put no money in yeah worse comes to
worse I'll do that but I like your way
better I'll at least try it yeah thanks
guys and you know the other thing I
would
do and this sounds manipulative but it's
not because it's the truth I would just
you're a I would sit down in front of
them personally if you can do they live
there no it's just renters at the
property that's part of the problem
that's why they don't care it's part of
the problem too okay oh no not them in
particular they they've no but they have
the renters have dogs that come in your
yard yes because the owner has not fixed
his fence this is a problem now it's
different yeah anyway do do the people
do you know the people that own it no no
not personally do they happen to live in
your area or do you know I don't know
that okay if you can find out it's
always better to talk about things in
person okay always better because and if
you can do that number one number two I
would tell them your story and your
story is hey I've never done anything
like this cuz I've never owned real
estate my husband died right after we
moved in here and I don't know how to
navigate this stuff so um I don't even
know if I could do that frankly I could
barely do it with you guys well if you
did it with us you can do it with them
yeah I suppose yeah you can do it 24
million people just listening in on
conversation so that's right I mean
imagine you can have a one duper over a
cup of coffee all right so uh but yeah
just just sit down and go look I lost my
husband in June and I don't know how to
do all this stuff but here's an idea I
had your your your renter's dogs are
getting in my yard my dogs are getting
in your yard and and the fence is on
your property so it's your fence but
I'll chip in with you on your fence I
got some bids like Jade said it's 400
bucks I'll put in 200 if you guys will
put in 200 would you would you help out
help out a neighbor here and let's get
this fixed up yeah and you know it's
hard to turn that one down and it's also
worth mentioning that you're trying to
avoid something bigger because if you
guys' dogs get to fighting if somebody's
dog bites another dog like I can just
see this snowballing into a bigger issue
and if the owner is going to want to
avoid that at all cost if they know
what's going on well you know what I'm
saying because one more one more word to
have one more reason to not have uh
Runners with dogs but what do I know so
I love dogs love dogs me and my dogs
spent time together this morning right
before I came to work but uh none but I
hate dogs as a landlord so we don't have
any we don't have any Ramsey houses with
dogs in them not not legally anyway
there might be some illegal aliens but
not not legally so illegal alien dogs
yeah yeah Dave have a heart people they
got to bring their they can't bring
their pet I know they the problem is
they don't make them behave just like
some people children right that's right
and then I got a house is all torn up
cuz I didn't have a
backbone anyway that's what's happening
so there you go there you go and then
the fence falls down that's dog knocked
it down I know what
happened this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the ramsy baby steps go to ramseys
solutions.com and click the get started
button we'll help you figure out the
best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America open phones at
88255 225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us again
5225 Mark starts off this hour in
Springfield Missouri hey Mark welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hey Dave um I got a question I know
how the baby steps work but I'm i' I've
got a little bit of a quandry as to
where I need to put my wife's student
loans in this because she is still in
school and not having to pay on them so
do I put them in because she's got 12
loans do I put them in where they go and
slow my snowball down or do I put them
at the end and continue my snowball
until I get to them I'd put them in
where they go she's got 12 of them so
I'd list i' I'd put those in smallest to
larges along with your other debts and
you might have one student loan and then
a credit card and then a student loan
and then a car payment and then you know
it doesn't all have to be by group and I
think sometimes in our minds we want it
to be that way but that's okay just put
them in as they go smallest to largest
how much student loan debt is there it's
58,000 and how much other debt is there
uh there's two cars um one is 9,000 and
one is
13,000 and the student loans only one of
them is more than the first car so I'm
going to be paying we're going to be
doing like 11 student loans and then a
car yeah it's
46,000 that I'm not gonna be building
what's your household in yeah you won't
be building any snowballing because you
don't have any payments on those to
cancel out I got you yes that's a good
point um so the uh what's your income
the household income is 170,000 and when
does she
graduate uh she'll graduate um she she's
doing part-time schooling so she's got
uh I think six semesters left and we can
have both of the cars paid off before
that are they are they subsidized or are
they
unsubsidized she's got two that are
getting taxes not taxes uh interest and
the rest of them aren't um say uh 58 and
right you said 58,000 student loan debt
and how much other yeah and then uh
9,000 on one car and 13 on another oh
okay so 31 and
58 right so 80 89,000 it's l than that
no we're at 880,000 we're right at
880,000 yeah okay all right 79,000 I
added it wrong okay um and you make
170,000 yes okay explain to me why you
can't pay all this in a
year because we have eight
kids wow they don't eat that much you
can raise eight kids on 100 grand
well we the the eight kids are all
teenagers you can raise eight kids on
100 Grand man there's Sports there's
food there's all that stuff it's just
it's a year
sacrifice yeah um cuz
170 minus 79 is one year you're debt
free MH I mean if you can't do any a
year you'll be able do it in 14 months
uh I think you're looking you know when
you said she's going to be six semesters
and you're just going to barely have two
cars paid off you're not making any
progress at all no we'll we'll have
we'll have the two cars paid off by
August of next year yeah you ought to
have you ought to be done by August of
next year the whole stinking thing are
close so are you paying cash for her
College as she goes yes we we have
stopped with the student loans we are
paying cash for everything now good and
what is she
studying uh she's getting her master's
in uh
business like it's not that NBA but it's
it's a a business okay and her intention
is to do what with her career with eight
kids uh to help me wear on my business I
see okay while you have eight kids yes
that are teenagers okay yes all right
and good well you're doing well with
your business sir is the 170,000 taxable
net profit on your business or is that
your gross
revenues the the hund aund of it is from
my business that's the uh the taxes and
everything no that's before taxes and
everything before before before
expenses yes what do you take home from
the business as
payment um well I've been taking home uh
just
$800 a week now what are you paying
taxes on on the $100,000 of Revenue that
this business creates you do not have a
household income of $170 that's why you
couldn't see doing this cuz you don't
have a net profit of 100,000 on the
business that's your gross revenues okay
yeah I'm not sure what it will be this
year because I I didn't make this much
last year so what you make last year
last year last year I only made 50,000
gross gross yeah did you net anything on
that uh not much we we still with the
money that she paid in for her taxes we
still got a tax return
so and we have we have fixed that I know
that you don't like to hear tax so we
have fixed that I'm still trying to
figure out if your business is making a
profit do you know what a profit is yes
I know what a profit is it's your
taxable income on the
business yes on $50,000 did you have to
pay any
taxes no because then you lost money on
$50,000 worth of Revenue with with what
my wife paid in on on her check here's
your wife your wife check's got nothing
to do with your business's profitability
you need to hire someone to run your
books yeah you need you sit and learn
how to do a set of books that's the next
you you don't even have any idea if
you're making a
profit cuz a profit is your gross
revenues minus the expenses associated
with the business equals profit and I'm
not sure you made a profit on 50 Grand
so I'm not sure you're making a profit
on 100 Grand thus I think you're trying
to raise kids on 70
grand actual Revenue which is your your
actual other income not business related
income and yeah you're not going to pay
it off in a year doing that so we need
to figure out whether this calculation
right to tell you if my advice was bogus
but I have bad information from you mhm
even still they're still going to have
to walk through a debt snowball and if
the business is not making money they're
going to have to find more money coming
in yeah in order to make this happen
fast with eight kids you need to quit
running getting a master's degree to run
a business it isn't profit not making
money yeah that's that's losing money at
that point yeah it's already losing
money probably I can't tell can't tell
cuz he doesn't know but anyway yeah get
to the bottom let's figure out if you're
making a profit or not and if you're
expanding that cuz you definitely
increase your revenues but I'm not sure
you increased your profits because if
you lose 25 cents of watermelon you
don't just get a bigger truck that's not
how this works so
um all right uh then based on all of
that what would I do yeah I might pay
off the car first and let the student
loans set to the side for a minute at
least get rid of one of the dad gun
payments out of your tip budget but I I
can't tell what your budget is so it's
really hard to tell you if it's worth
doing that if you truly made a profit of
100,000 which I think we've established
you didn't um then you had $170,000
actual household income then I would go
back to my original thing and say shut
up and pay off the loans in a year or 14
months if 79,000 should go away but I
don't think that's the numbers so I
think it changed in the middle of the
conversation they did this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Sha
hey folks Dr John delone here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great great
place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember halow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality open
phones at
5225 J is my co-host today by the way
folks uh I do a show called The entree
leadership podcast where I take calls on
small business and we talk about the
five stages of business and what it
takes to level up in those five stages
the six drivers that do that we've got a
whole system for teaching small
businesses to grow and run it's the
Playbook the book entree leadership is a
number one bestseller it's the Playbook
that we've used to run ramsy and we've
grown it in 30 years from a card table
in my living room to about a $300
million company so we'll walk you
through this stuff and when you're at
that beginning stage is a called a
treadmill operator when it's just you
and all the revenue and all the
production counts on you you kind of
just own your job at that point when
you're a small business person and
you're doing all the work and um you
know and the revenue comes in because of
you the production comes in because of
you all that kind of stuff it's a one or
two maybe a thre man lady show whatever
there uh that's the normal way everyone
starts but those are the stages that you
have to get things in place like a good
set of accounting books a good set of
books uh to where you know what's
happening with your money if you do not
make the money behave and those of you
in the construction world the remodeling
world you do job costing and you know
which each job is profitable so you
learn to do your estimating properly you
you know you set up you know can I
afford to hire someone well you have to
can I afford to buy a piece of equipment
or can I afford to rent another space
uh you have to be able to take look at
your numbers and see if you have a
profit to be able to do that because a
business that doesn't make a profit it's
called a hobby MH it's kind of a harsh
hobby actually because you're delusional
and I've done it accidentally a time or
two are do you run a not for profit not
intentionally but there's a time or two
that I almost have yeah so uh but yeah
that's a uh you know so if you want to
learn more entree leadership is the is
one of the top business and Leadership
podcast out there you can join me I do
it once a week and it's on the Ramsey
networks and we would love to have you
join us and check out the whole entree
leadership brand we've got events you
can come to uh we've got a whole U
subscription process where we coach you
called Elite and so all of that falls
into that bucket for that our last
caller uh Jeff is in Cleveland Ohio hi
Jeff welcome to the Ramsey show Hello
thank you very much for taking my call I
really appreciate it sure what's up um
I'm 52 years old my wife is 51 and a
couple years ago she was diagnosed with
a form of
dementia um so we are navigating that um
as far as our financials go we have a
will a financial power of attorney
healthc care power attorney a living
will in place good um she's no longer on
the deed of the house but she has
lifetime access to the residence through
the will um she has no property or any
bank accounts in her name at all we have
our six
emergency fund why did you take
everything out of her name uh that's
what the attorney had said for what I I
uh because she because she might misuse
them if she if her dementia is
Advanced uh it might be for Medicare or
Medicaid I'm not sure Medicaid is for
poor people that's
welfare yeah it only works no that won't
work okay um okay and so you were doing
real good you got all the documentation
in place and uh how much do you have in
Investments uh as far as uh a Roth we
have 340 and as far as my workplace 401K
have
95,000 um within the last couple months
probably maybe three months uh I stopped
contributing to my 401k my RW so I could
pile up money and a couple weeks ago I
paid off my house good for you really
really good so we're so we're on step
seven um which kind of brings me to my
question um with Ohio and
Medicaid uh the spouse can have up to
$140,000 in
assets except if you put the Roth IRAs
and payout status in an rmd payout
status those are not counted as
assets
soy Hey listen yeah
um you're you're trying to figure out a
way way to put your wife you didn't mean
to but you're trying to figure out a way
to put your wife in a welfare nursing
home oh Medicaid Medicaid is Medicaid is
welfare you don't want to do it's for
poor it's for poor people and you don't
need to do that okay and and the
guidelines are there to keep it from
people that are only poor people putting
people in those nursing homes okay okay
and you're not poor people you can take
care of your wife man I'm so sorry
you're facing this but you've done a
great job with money and you're in a
position to love your wife well yeah
yeah um just want to get everything that
I can out of the way so I know but but
but the the goal the goal is to take
care of her the goal is not to put her
in a Medicaid nursing home right right
let's change let's change the goal and
you evidently make good money what do
you make uh I make about 73 a year
you've done a really good job on 73 dude
is she still working oh no she she's on
uh Medicare she's not able to work drive
now okay so it's advancing
then yeah I'm soorry I'm sorry man
that's tough so where where are we today
does she know everyone still or what how
far progressed
um we have uh we have appointments every
six months uh last appointment you know
the doctor was able to notice some
decline uh she'll go through some more
testing in another six months um but she
is able you know she is at home um she
knows you oh yeah yeah okay do you not
but you're but you're noticing
deterioration you know it varies some
days are better than others always yeah
yeah all right
um okay you're you're right to do what
you've done every single thing you've
done I agree with I think you've done a
wonderful job sir you're a good man okay
and I and I would I would agree with
your last part of your financial moves
to pile up cash and pile up cash and
pile up cash and the next stage that is
fairly inexpensive compared to nursing
home is inh Home
Care yeah okay and so if you can pile up
another 100 Grand before you need inhome
care you probably have that earmarked
then to take care of her for uh to pay
for you know a nurse or help of some
kind uh of some level of professional to
come in and help you and there may be a
few days at the end of life
that that she will have to have care
that is beyond in home but maybe not
maybe not um I can tell you this okay
Sharon and I have got um we're
multi-millionaires and so I'm 63 I do
not have nursing home insurance I'm a
multi-millionaire I I will be at
home I can afford full-time care for my
wife if something happens to her and you
can too because you've done such a good
job um but you're catching it way
earlyer ear but I mean by the time if
something happens to Sharon and she's at
home I can provide all the services of a
nursing home privately with a private
freaking Butler okay and it's still less
expensive than a nursing home but I've
just got that option and you've just
about got yourself in that position in a
in a very heartbreaking situation you
have been very um intentional and wise
I'm so proud of you well thank you i'
I've just followed your principles well
you you you you had a you had an extra
um grenade thrown in the middle of it
and so uh it throws you off kilter but
you you know only if you are completely
broke if listen if you go visit a
Medicaid nursing home and you go visit a
private Care nursing home that you pay
for you'll see what I'm talking about
okay there there are a few of them that
are excellent but it's government
housing yeah versus private
residence okay that's the I mean it it's
it's it's welfare it's what's for it's
okay I'm not mad and I'm not talking
down my nose to somebody or something
like that but if you've got the means
your job is not to try to to dodge using
your money your job is to use your money
because that's what is forceed take care
of her yeah I think he's done a great
job wow in such a difficult situation
they're they're so young early 50s man
that's tough yeah and early onset has a
long lifespan it does so um poent
potentially so um yeah this could be a
decade yeah but thankfully he did set
himself up paid for mortgage man he's
been investing he couldn't have done any
better very wise very wise
heartbreaking this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
solutions you can drop in and have free
homemade chocolate chip cookies and
coffee anytime time you want we do this
show from 1: to 4: central Time Monday
through Friday it's completely free to
come in and watch ugly paint dry on the
wall no we're here it's fine it's fine
very we're very entertaining so you
don't want to miss it there's always 50
to 200 folks sitting out here there's a
museum or whatever you call it a
timeline of the everything that's
happened around here it's fun to visit
the lobby and have an experience as a
part of your Nashville visit we'd love
to have you in the lobby also is a stage
right in front of our windows we call it
the debt-free stage on it is David and
Lisa hey guys how are you morning good
how are you better than I deserve
welcome where do you live we live in
Austin area little town called Liberty
Hill oh yeah fun welcome to Nashville
good to have you guys so how much debt
have you paid off paid off almost
$300,000 or right at
$300,000 wow good for you and how long
did that take real slow 5 years ago took
about 5 years to get rid of it and your
range of income during that time uh we
started at
125,000
and we ended last year at 360 wow what
do yall do for a living uh my wife is
retired now those are the agreement of
paying off the
Housey but um I do s I'm 100% commission
salesperson in the hbac industry my
commercial hbac oh yeah way to go man
amazing so your house is gone and paid
off house is gone and paid off we
looking at weird
people wow what's the house worth um 500
nice how much is in your
Investments uh the last year has hurt us
a little bit but right around 400 so
you're right out a million yeah we're
right there way to go baby steps
millionaires paid for house how old are
you I'm 41 I'm 42 all right am that
feels good yeah how's it feel to not
have a payment in the world nice it's
nice it definitely feels special so we
feel like we've been blessed and we
don't feel like we deserve what we have
well you do deserve it but but we're
better than we deserve yeah there we go
wow so was it only the house or was
there other debt included in the 300,000
we had 242,000 on the house and then we
had about 50,000 in cars and then we had
crit the rest was credit cards so we did
the credit card we did the snowball got
credit cards first and then we actually
we traded some cars we did some things
to get rid of that debt and then and
then we just worked on the house um we
actually paid 192,000 in the last 16
months you've been making serious money
Lisa what did you do before you retired
I've worked as a receptionist I worked
as a school as a par professional for 5
years okay and you said I'm in but when
we're done I'm done yes yes I'm not mad
at that I like it yeah want to focus on
our daughter Claire who's here with us
to today and well it gives you a reason
to push forward like that that's
excellent now you got now you're just an
old retired person at 42 had your reward
at the end I love that yeah yeah so what
else are you planning to do I mean
you've got you don't have a payment in
the world is there a trip is there
something fun that you're going to do to
celebrate this is kind of our trip we
kind of no you got to do better than
that we we got was cool but you got to
do better well we we came in s Saturday
to do this and then we're going to go to
Nashville till next weekend this was
kind of our whole like we wanted to do
this I've been a couple of times on
business but they've never been so it's
something that we wanted to do together
we love the area so we're going to we're
going to head into Nashville tonight and
stay till Saturday yep oh good it's fun
you'll have a blast you'll have a blast
thank you guys no we appreciate you I
mean like I said we uh one of the things
that we find interesting is I have a
degree in history and I fell into hbac
and just never got out and we feel like
God has a plan for us because we should
never have done what we've done not with
uh I wanted to be a teacher and never
got to do it so I uh fell into HVAC
sales and never got out so but they all
you know it doesn't always work out the
way we plan so okay so how did you
originally get connected with us in this
process um I've done FPU through church
a few times and we taught it once at our
house during coid and everything and we
saw you when you came to Austin a couple
years ago you come to Austin a couple
times actually I have a constant
reminder of a key chain with your
yeah yeah live like no one else so we
have a constant reminder um but it's
something that you know we've we've
supported and we love and yeah we have
family that my dad you know we grew up
like in debt all the time and my dad's
running the program now we're running
the program my brother just sold some
houses to pay off his debt and get stuff
so we've got the family is in a better
place because you know we're all
following you now changing your family
tree absolutely all the
limbs that's what we're trying to we're
trying to do lead by example right yeah
well done very well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is I mean you're debt free in your
40s house and everything baby steps
millionaires pretty impressive just
commitment being on the same page you
know we've sacrificed a lot and said no
to a lot of things but what was the
deepest cut on the sacrifice the thing
you remember that was the biggest
ouchie I mean probably vacations just
and family stuff we used to do a lot of
Barbecues in the summer times and during
football season where we'd have people
and we kind of just cut it all off cuz
it got real expensive oh yeah doing it
every weekend it starts up real fast so
we we made a lot of sacrifices where we
were those crazy people where we just
weren't doing a lot of fun and we were
trying to do little day trips here and
there instead of like big vacations and
we we've become professionals at having
breakfast for dinner at least twice a
week and we've continued that so I was
going to say breakfast for dinner is
that really a sacrifice cuz that's
that's legitimate it's a sacrifice for
them but now all now all that stops no
we well no I mean I mean if you want to
do it you can do it but the breakfast on
your I mean it says on your keychain
live like no one else so later you can
live like no one else and give like no
one else want you to enjoy this now yeah
and we plan to and it's it's just
something that's hard to break when
you've been doing it for 5 years I know
but it's football season dude get the
barbecue going get the barbecue going
man get it back going again it's time
you you did a good job You've Won you
sacrificed to win now enjoy the winnings
that's right well done proud of you guys
very good what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you told
me that right you said commitment and
sacrifice but I didn't let I didn't let
David answer yeah so the hardest thing
for me is finding contentment I know
Rachel talks about it all the time and
my wife tells me all the time is just
finding we we've worked together really
well but the budget is the biggest thing
um you always say to let the other
person you know I'm the one that
controls the budget but I've always
given her you know she's always looked
it over and made some change I forced
her to make a change every single time
so that she was committed to the process
good um but working together through the
whole thing I mean I couldn't have done
it without them I mean yeah the process
of you know I kind of bribed her a
little bit with the retirement thing
that as soon as we get it done you can
retire but in reality I think she just
gave you her terms yes well I don't
think you bried her at all said this is
this is what it takes to get me in yeah
this is what it takes to get where we
want to be so good we're excited about
it Go terms of surrender well done very
well done all right you guys excellent
job hey we've got the live and give box
for you uh the baby steps millionaires
you made it there or almost so close
we're calling it and depending on
whether the market goes up today or
tomorrow there you go and a Total Money
Makeover book to give away to someone
and a Financial Peace University
membership to give away while you're
continuing to lead classes thank you for
leading the classes it makes a big
difference people go to those classes as
you know their life gets changed yeah
and uh you got it's because of people
like you coordinating so thank you for
being a coordinator we really really
appreciate it and you're a perfect
example too I know right we appreciate
everything you do yes well God bless
y'all all right David and Lisa and
Claire Austin Texas area 300,000 paid
off house and
everything weird people baby steps
millionaires did it in 5 years making
125 up to now 360 count it down let's
hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1 we're debt
free
yeah 11
yes man oh man oh
man hey those two leaned in they sure
did pretty incredible the whole family
that's that's that's well done well
played this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
St
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one an online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now to get up
to 50% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is
my co-host Today podcast
reviews five stars the jerant on the
student loans was powerful she really
painted the depth of the problem and the
hurt that can come from them the best
rent I've heard in months it should be
required listening to every semester of
high school and college way to go Jade a
jade rant a jade rant there you go so
have you uh have you previously named
that or um I think they got it from the
Dave rant oh I think it's a subsidiary
okay sub holy owned subsidiary okay uh I
drive every morning as an Uber lift
driver in New York City I listen to
podcast with my passengers some don't
pay any attention but those that do
listen ask and become interested I share
my experience and my baby steps that I'm
at and I really enjoy getting
compliments from the other Ramsay
followers wow that get into the C get
into the Uber yeah uh glad I'm not the
only listener in New York City well I'm
I love that I'm glad you're not too but
I'm glad both of you found each other no
I'm kidding a buch that's how I found
you if somebody had you on the car radio
my brother had you on the car radio well
there you go forced forced listening
there you go Lara's in Sarasota hi laara
welcome to the ramsy
show hi Dave how are you better than we
deserve what's
up so I have a question we're paying off
the L of our debt I have about 6 ,000 on
my car I just want to know do you think
I should be able to get my nails done
while I do
that I am unqualified to answer this
question as I am to answer can I get my
hair done when you uh do this so however
Jade is sitting next to me with
floresent nails she is qualified uh so
what Sam and I did when we were paying
off our debt is we kind of I I did not
get my nails done and every so often I
was able to get my hair done so it was a
tradeoff off because it can get
expensive if you're going every 2 weeks
and you're doing the hair thing and
you're doing I don't know what you're
getting your eyebrows you know whatever
done it get another thing I'm
inexperienced at you you don't wa there
a whole bunch of these things I don't
know anything about so the point is it's
a lot of grooming it can get expensive
um some of it it's like yeah you need
somebody to cut your hair every now and
then or you need you know whatever that
is but Nails truly is one of those
things that it is get your nails done
Laura it's about $50 each time so and
how often how often would this come
up it's every two weeks yeah was right
on the hammer y okay all right and so I
I you know I grew up redneck hillbilly
so I don't know anything about this but
when I was growing up people did their
own Nails is that a
possibility see I work in professional
uh industry and I have really brittle
nails and so when I don't have them done
I they look gross and disgusting I
wasn't say I wasn't say gross and
disgusting I said I mean like I mean my
my little sister like they would paint
stuff on there do y'all still do that I
mean do humans do that do them
themselves ever no every all the women
are shaking their head you can paint
like I'm from another planet you can
paint them but she wants an application
that's going to make them hard so that
they don't break and I will say um Laura
you can you can buy the dip powder and
you can do those yourself and it is a
lot less expensive I don't do it but I
have friends that do
it and that might be did you do it when
you weren't getting your nails done no
because I but yours weren't brittle no
they weren't brittle or I'm learning so
much today you can even buy the jar of
like the hard gel that you can polish on
and so that's that'll save your nails
without you having to get them done
where is Rachel Cruz when I need I feel
your pain though look I feel her pain is
that's a sacrifice but it's only
temporary what's your household
income we make about 200,000 and the
66,000 on the car is the only thing we
have left but who whose car the yours or
his it's mine sell the car and yeah we
are so we are that's our plan we're
gonna sell the car obviously we're
upside down on it so we're GNA have
we're going to take our three to six
months and pay off the difference and
then I'll get like a $20,000 car and
we'll pay that off in about three to
four months and then we'll pay the house
off wait a minute how much do you have
in
savings we have about 15,000 in savings
and that pays off the difference when
you sell the car but then you were going
to go finance a $220,000
car yes no I don't think I would do
that
wow okay so here here's the thing
um I mean we had a lot of fun with your
nail question and it's fine to talk
about 100 bucks here you make $200,000 a
year you got other problems than 100
bucks so how How Deeply do youall I mean
it feels like he cut your nails and cut
your nail budget back and he's still
buying like tools and stuff at Home
Depot or something I don't know where in
the flip is 200,000 going then we can't
pay 66 off minus 15 which is 51 in about
four or five months why don't you pay
this car
off our our house payment is about 31 00
a month to be bought at the
height still that should be
fine okay so you have $36,000 a year
going out on a house payment you make
um yeah I guess that's a good question
maybe we need to sit down you do a
budget we are going to start doing a
budget okay you don't cut you don't cut
your nails out until you guys get the
rest of this fixed yeah when you sit
down and do a budget that's going to
reveal the budget is like blood work it
reveals everything going on where the
money's going where the problem is and
so when you sit down and do that you're
going to realize oh I've got bigger fish
to yeah nails if you want to cut that
that's fine but you're going to see all
the little things that's making
this difficult here's the thing if you
guys have gone through your budget
together with a fine tooth comb and
you've slam dunked your
$200,000 income towards 51,000 cuz you
got 15,000 in the bank to throw at this
um I think you're going to find a lot
more opportunities to get your uh get
your goals hit very quickly than your
nails and the fact that your nails were
set over to the side is the issue while
you guys still haven't done the budget
um kind of makes me want to fuss at him
because he has you guys got to get in
there together and he's got a I'm just
telling you there's some crap he's doing
that's more than those stupid nails when
you get in the budget you're going to
find it yeah yeah there's there's
something he's that he's got that's his
little pet thing
and he didn't want to give up the gym
membership while he's making you cut
your cut cut out the nails all that I I
only know this because I'm the guy that
did that kind of stuff so um but yeah I
think when you both have a very clear
print out of what's going on like Jade
said the blood work is done you get your
every dollar budget both of you are
looking at it both of you say we're
willing to cut
deeply and then we're not going to cut
out $100 a month for this or we are
going to cut out $100 a month cuz it's
only for 5 months yeah I'll do them
myself for 5 months but you're giving
that over there up and we're not going
out to eat and we're not going on
vacation and we're not doing this and
we're not doing that and we're not doing
this if I'm giving up the nails that's a
fair statement are you guys putting a
lot into
retirement yeah so we actually did
complete dat the Financial Peace
University uh during the co time and we
paid off all of our debt and then we
made a stupid decision we bought a
stupid car and then we bought another
stupid car and we don't have piece
anymore so we're getting back into Fu
and you've still got your retirement
coming
out yes and my guess is it's quite a bit
it's not just 15 is it it's not
$50 no it's more than that that I arest
my case there you go okay get back on
the detailed scorched Earth baby step
two budget the two of you together stop
your retirement use all non-retirement
funding to clear this car up you're
right it was a stupid decision yes you
fell off the wagon yes you're getting
back on the wagon but that's not we
don't go straight to the you can't get
your nails done while I put 15% into
retirement that's right thank you hello
he's not following our system okay we're
telling you to stop everything and get
this done and then I may cut the nails
too not cut the nails cut the nail uh
expenditure treatment out uh whatever
the flip you call it and um anyway but
that's more symbolic with your income
that you've gotten everything else going
than it is is actual yeah does that make
sense and sometimes because you're
changing Behavior symbolic things
symbolic sacrifices are
valuable okay I remember I had a old boy
from the country at Financial Peace
University one time he came in big old
guy and his wife was sitting in a small
group crying and she said I love my
husband so much he just sold his knife
collection and it was like his prize
thing yeah meant a lot to but he said my
wife and my kids future means more than
those kn he said 1100 bucks it didn't
really matter cuz they had $60,000 in
debt but was it was symbolic that he's
putting the family before me woo this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show Dave here you can find all of our
shows with the Ramsey Network app on
your smartphone it's the only place to
listen to the entire back catalog of
episodes download the Ramsey Network app
in your favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at
5225 you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Derek is in Arkansas
and starts off this hour hey Derek
what's
up hey Derek sorry hey Dave um thank you
for taking my call um I'll get right to
the point my wife wife just wrote a New
York Times bestselling book um that
released less than a month ago um we've
already started to see some income from
that most recently a check for $50,000
that came in on the the date of the
release um and then I'm a longtime
listener first-time caller uh listen
ever since I was a missionary in Nepal
um my supervisors gave me your materials
over 10 years ago and just appreciate
what you do so my wife and I U were
talking about this and she recently uh
got a message from Rachel Cruz who
reached out to her to my wife and um and
just said she had read the book and uh
so my wife and I thought well you know
we really appreciate you guys and the
principles that you stand for so I
wanted to um just call in and see what
your thoughts were about what we should
do with um some of the income that we're
getting I've already maxed up my
retirement in my job um we're debt free
um we've already maxed out a Roth ir and
didn't know if we should open a a
brokerage account um just with an S&P
index um S&P 500 Index Fund so the house
is paid
off yes sir yes sir you're 100% debt
free and
everything that's correct way to go dude
how old are
y'all I'm 34 my wife is 32 so this so
This 50,000 on the book is spare change
right now it's you're over and above the
baby
steps well we're on baby steps I guess
it would be five and seven um we've got
three boys uh ages one to eight
so um okay so you might want to use some
of the 50 for Education you're
saying correct we have thought about
that U didn't know if we should put a
certain percentage of that toward kids
college and then uh some toward a an
index fund just to keep some liquid cash
because if we did move we would want to
pay cash for a house so if there was how
much is in your emergency
fund uh about $50,000 right now not
counting the book deal what's your
normal household income
uh fluctuates irregular um I just
graduated graduated from law school and
uh started Prosecuting last year so uh
we had uh with partial year work last
year about uh 65 uh looking at about 150
this year and about 85 next year and
that's just my income plus a little bit
of income in addition to like my wife
brings in from social media and things
like that yeah well done well played
yeah I think you got it down it's
exactly what I would do with it I would
if it were me and I had that money in
your shoes I'd probably break it into
thirds and give save spend it I'd give
some of it I'd save a third you know for
your college fund or whatever you have
set up 529s and then I'd come up with
something you guys want to do maybe
you're saving for a trip maybe it's you
know a vehicle you're saving for
whatever that spinage that you're
wanting and I'd break it up like that or
maybe in fourths since you've got two
kids you put a quarter for each of them
for
Education you think just opening one
account and then um for
from from Child correct for put a little
I'd open three I'd put a little in each
of their names oh it's three kids I'm
sorry I said two but yeah and the reason
I do that Derek is just so I can tell
them over and over that this is their
college fund which presupposes that
they're going to college and then if we
want to change that as they get later in
life I can not force it on them but I
just want to brainwash them that
continuous learning throughout your life
is a brilliant idea like you went back
to law school after the mission field
okay so continuous learning after after
you know if the last thing you read
That's non-fiction After High School is
nothing then you're not going to grow in
life so you adding learning whatever it
is whether it's for your education or
not uh isn't there so Rachel reached out
to your wife about her New York Times
bestselling book so uh your wife is
Jill yes Jill duer now Dillard yeah yeah
counting the cost is the book right
right yeah okay all right so the Jill
Dugger book yeah yeah cuz Rachel and I
were talking about the other day and uh
cuz the book is impressive and Rachel
was saying she was going to try to get
her on the show or at least do some kind
of social media collab with her yeah
okay well I didn't know about that but
that's probably why she reached out to
her yeah cuz we were both she and I were
talking about your old story and your
life and everything um and um because
I'm I'm uh of course old and I remember
all that stuff uh from years ago uh the
whole Gothard thing and all that stuff
and then it's very interesting it's very
interesting and so um and then to see
what you guys have done as a couple is
impressive but you guys are really it's
very cool at least the outside looking
in I have I don't know you personally
obviously but um well now I have to read
the book yeah you
do what' you say it was called It's
called counting the
cost a lot of it really goes into what
especially John deloney goes into
and his his influence recently has
helped us as a couple so appreciate this
wonderful thing of boundaries and
forgiveness correct and not you know not
not don't spend your whole life being
defined by bitterness and so on so yeah
it's pretty cool and uh you you're I
didn't know the part about you going
back to law school that's very
impressive good for you thank you so
well done dude decided to go back to law
school through through all of this and
and well the book just came out so it
hit the times in the last few weeks
right right two weeks ago it hit the
times congratulations came on the 12
thank you yeah that's that's impressive
yeah because the times is not known for
putting Christians on the on their list
so um they're kind of known for not
doing it actually but yeah but right
that's I'm glad you did that's awesome
man very good very good yeah so I'm with
Jade I would go thirds uh throw some at
the kids to make sure we got the college
thing beefed up a little you're going to
have enough income to make sure they're
okay on educational choices later in
life anyway you're going to be fine um
and enjoy some of it and be generous
with some of it I'm with her give save
spin give save spin love that very cool
that's exciting very cool how do you get
on the New York Times best like how does
that work uh it's up to them has nothing
to do with actual numbers sales it's not
sales no it's an editorial list so they
decide so like it's not off it's not
unusual for one of our books to outs
sell their number one yeah about about 5
to one well that's what I know that's
yeah that's pretty standard yeah
basically my rule is New York Times
sucks so well now they're not going to
put you on the they were not going to
put me on anyway I've said they suck for
a long time I've been on there a couple
times been there done that didn't help
me a bit didn't change anything no one
ever no one ever sent me a check cuz I
was a New York Times bestseller not once
uh but but because I had a best seller
I've gotten a lot of checks because that
means we sold an actual number of books
that's a different what counts I guess
but I'm glad they got on I'm not being
not being jealous of them I'm happy for
young couple with a brand new book and
and the Apparently I haven't read it but
apparently the book is good rightel was
talking about it so good stuff that's
fun you never know never know who's in
our audience I know this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show hey hey hey hey hey hey
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones
5225 Riley's in Raleigh North Carolina
hi Riley welcome to the ramsy
show hi Dave hi Jay how you doing great
what's
up so uh I am
considering selling my condo and because
I've got some neighbors that I not too
happy with and the housing market is
expensive in the area so I'm considering
selling my condo moving into an
apartment and using the money I make
from selling my condo to pay off my
student loans and if I did that I would
have no debt and I'm just curious as to
whether or not that is a good
choice so you want to sell your condo
your neighbors are kind of annoying you
don't necessarily want to be paying for
this anyway how much student loan debt
do you have it's about 88,000 what were
your condo sell
for um I think it would sell for uh
around 260 or 27
so My Equity would be around around
$100,000 okay so you owe around 160 or
170 okay and what do you make yeah yeah
uh I make about 95 and how old are
you uh 32 and you're
single correct okay how long have you
had the
condo um just about exactly three years
what's wrong with the
neighbors um so they are rent they're
they're below me and um it's been a
plethora of issues over the course of
the years different different bad RS in
that same unit over the course of three
years uh smoking uh really loud dogs
that are left on their porch I live
above them the dogs that are under me
barking waking me up all night and and
uh on top of that and the the owner of
the unit and the HOA are not helpful do
you think want it I'm just wondering why
is the HOA not
helpful they basically just don't do
anything you you make complaints and
they um you know it's it's a very
laidback HOA I would say which I guess
in some ways could be good but in in my
circumstance it's you know not helpful
yeah I okay there's a couple things
number one if you want to do your plan
that's fine
um sometimes there's a uh um sometimes
there's a time to leave and um I'm not
selling something that I own because of
renters and an HOA that won't do its job
I'm going to start jacking some people
up like if the HOA got a letter from
your attorney that said we're getting
ready to sue you guys for viol for not
doing your job which is making the
rental units have renters that freaking
behave that's like the hoa's job in a
condo they don't do much else MH that's
what you're paying for yeah correct time
for Barney F to get his one bullet out
which is always who runs the HOA right
yeah you're right is there anything else
about the condo that would make you want
to leave other than the neighbors um you
I would like to you know if if it was
more affordable I would like to purchase
a home that the the situation is I
bought my condo in 2020 and the interest
rates are really low so I've got a very
cheap con you know it's cheap to live
there right now I'm paying around 1,00
total with the H fees whereas if I want
to buy even a small home in the area you
know the interest rates are now around
7% so I don't have really a cheap I
don't have an equivalent option right um
and you know is a small condo it's it's
a place I would not live in you know for
a long time anyway it's okay to sell it
Jake I'll tell you the other problem
you're going to run into when you sell
it the real estate agent that comes over
to list it is going to smell smoke and
hear parking dogs
mhm I know I am worried about that and
they're going to they're going to say
this is going to affect your buyers so
these people have devalued your condo by
their
misbehavior yeah like it's not going to
bring as much because people aren't
going to want to pay for a smoke
infested dog barking bunch of crap well
that's one reason that he needs to yeah
you got to get this guys yeah this HOA
yeah yeah they they really G to have to
stop it I mean it's it's ridiculous so
and it's frustrating because it's not
like it's not 247 bad where you know I
could see an instance where um because
it's it's what I've experienced where
sometimes I'll have a week where not
that bad and I feel like if there was
somebody you know a buyer looking at it
they might not notice that stuff but
then there are times when it is bad
where you know I could see both
instances where a buyer could come in
there at a bad time and say oh I'm not
buying this and I can the opposite to
because I'm the one I witness both
myself but you don't want to risk you
don't want to you don't want to gamble
that you know the the open house or you
know on the weekend the open houses is
the the weekend they're throwing a rager
call here's what you can do call the um
our jump online at ramseys solutions.com
find one of our real estate
Professionals in the area that we
endorse that are ramsy trusted tell them
when they come over to look to call the
HOA and say we're getting ready put this
on the market and if the renter
downstairs isn't behaving I'm going to
advise my client to sue your butt off
and let the realtor play the heavy and
see if we can straighten these renters
up for 30 days and get this thing
sold yeah yeah and then
move I I just I just have trouble
letting these people run me off without
that's it's exactly how I feel yeah I
feel like I don't like them controlling
my life you I don't you know because I
feel like I made a good purchase and you
know I have it's kind of what an HOA is
for it's so that you know if you want to
be a if you want to raise hell and throw
parties and have barking dogs you're
supposed to go out in the country not in
a condo project hello I mean this is not
it's not rocket surgery here people yeah
all right wow amazing I know right yeah
that that's what I would do I think you
put it on the market and let the real
estate agent call the HOA and uh tell
them to um tell tell them to be real
tough on them and to threaten them uh
that they I want this crap straightened
up seriously cuz I'm getting ready put
this house on on the market and if
there's condo on the market and if this
unit doesn't sell or it sells for Less
because of smoking dogs I'm coming after
y'all for the difference and the Val
lost value because you didn't manage the
property like your like your job is yes
why is that these HOAs man they're
usually they dri I hate them they drive
me nuts I live in one that drives me
nuts it's just God have you ever been on
the board of one
no can I tell you that one time were you
were I'm going to blame it on Sam Sam
was we were but it was really Sam man he
was trying to make a difference and they
did then he found out he found out what
yeah no it's just God I I should I'm the
guy that ought to be on a piece of
ground somewhere nowhere but I'd be
living by myself because my wife ain't
going to live there so I'm stuck with
these choices in my life yeah so I'm I'm
stuck worse than Riley is I mean it's
you know so yeah Riley's in a pretty bad
way yeah it's bad sell it get you an
apartment then immediately start saving
and get back in the real estate market
as quickly as you possibly can Riley uh
let's not let this be a reason you don't
own a piece of property two years from
now so many people are struggling with
that his main thought though which is I
bought I have such a low interest rate
and I'm stuck and now I'm just I have to
L people are waiting on rates to come
down to move because of that I know and
I got bad news for you it's going to be
a while boys and girls and while you're
house prices are going to go up they are
yes they are we told you that this time
last year and what we predicted is
exactly come true yeah we told you in a
real estate live stream that we did last
year at this time that rates were that
house prices were going to go up about
7% in the year 2023 and that's what
they're trending right now I mean I know
people who are sitting on the money they
could buy but they're just like uh it
like grosses them out cash no like to
have the right down payment but are just
grow grossing them out I'm like you get
a high interest rate when the rates come
down just refinance exactly or better
than that pay the stupid thing off and
get rid of the interest rate yeah you
know I mean there there's a couple ways
around this so yeah it it's but this
trying to time this stuff but it's a
generation that's never seen High
interest rates and this these are not
high interest rates by the way you need
to talk about this more often Dave 1982
when I got out of college they were 18%
177% fixed rate in ' 84 they were down
to 14% fixed rate now that's high and so
that's back when the dinosaurs roam the
Earth you Boomer yeah I know I know I
know how that works right but um but I
also know what high is cuz high is all
relative six is high if you've been used
to three that's right it's relative
there you go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
thanks for joining us America reminder
the money and marriage getaway October
19th and 21st is just a few days away
you and your spouse will be equipped
with tools to cast a vision for your
family set goals create a life you both
love uh you will have the undistracted
time to disconnect from everyday life
and reconnect
with your spouse interactive sessions
and all kinds of sessions with Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney on money
communication boundaries intimacy
tickets are $799 for this multi-day
event it's here on the Ramsey campus if
you're out of debt you got room in the
budget this is a must do the money and
marriage getaway a very luxurious
weekend here on the Ramsey campus um for
couples coming up October 19th through
the 21st check it out Ramsey
solutions.com events to get your tickets
now on the debt free stage in the
headquarters solution of Ramsey
Solutions here in the lobby uh Joshua
and Becca are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve welcome where you from We're
from Indianapolis Indiana all right
right how much have you paid off how
much debt $50,000 woohoo 50k and how
long did this take s months all right
wow Jack and your range of income during
that time 83 ,000 83 what do youall do
for a living I'm a personal fitness
coach mhm and I work at a church a local
church oh wonderful what kind of debt
was the 50k student loans all right
whose student loans yours or hers mine
yours all right how long you'all been
married a little over a year ah so we
get married and then we pay off Joshua
student loans yes first order of
business yep tell me the story what
happened here yeah so I grew up uh and
my dad was a big big fan of yours and so
he put that in us uh since we were
little growing up and uh so when I met
Joshua and he was like I have student
debt I was like oh no and so if you
weren't cute that'd be a deal breaker
right I know but he is so it worked um
but and so then we just like talked
about it and I actually like gave him
your book and he started reading it and
um applying it and so I knew that he
like had the ability like he wanted to
do this as well uh and so then well he's
a personal trainer for God seak
discipline is his middle name right
right yeah uh and so then he got the app
the uh every dollar app app and started
working that and making his own budget
and I remember he texted me one day he
was like I made a budget like look at it
I was like this is awesome look at it
yeah so you're a keeper I know I was
like that's awesome so um we made the
budget and then um decided when we got
married that uh my father had like saved
up money and had make us like a wedding
fund and so we were like I don't really
want a super big fancy wedding and I'd
rather like not have a lot of debt so we
did we got married in my parents front
yard and it was beautiful and awesome uh
and then we took the remainder of it and
then my savings uh and then we uh he
paid his savings and we paid it off so
wow wow boom just like that I mean you
attacked it we did yeah look at you
that's a sacrifice when you know there's
money that you can have this big wedding
a big party and you say no this is more
important that's one day this is the
rest of our life yeah exactly and I
think too just um growing up like being
Believers and just like knowing that
Christ sacrificed for us of just that
like he paid our Eternal debt and so
like At first I was like I don't want to
give him like my money but then it's
like no we're married like we're one and
like this is what Christ has done for us
and so to be able to like combine that
and like be truly one and like to pay
off that debt and was really really cool
so Joshua she comes at you with all this
stuff did you go like whoa I mean at
first it was a different approach
uh so I mean my my parents did Financial
Peace growing up I have a special needs
brother so you know the whole financial
situation was a little bit different uh
so to go from that you know to this it's
a completely different side of it you
know my parents did help us along the
way um but yeah I was like okay I got to
do something here I got to step up if
I'm going to be a husband I need to be a
leader and so I was like I got to make
change look at that how old are you too
I'm 27 she's 26 wait a go way to go
amazing well you leaned in knocked it
out fast and that's got to feel good you
got to feel strong oh yeah both of you I
mean you did grown up stuff here I know
right that was very very difficult I
mean exciting be Becca's uh not a
princess she like a woman no she's a
woman all right thank you she's got she
had a full agenda and a full plan and
made sure it got executed that's what
I'm talking about mean there's not
there's not yeah that's that's good
stuff well done y'all very well done
thank you thank you okay now that you've
done it uh you see the principles of the
process I mean you teach principles when
you're teaching as a as a trainer right
and uh you know we have principles that
are guiding these baby steps or guiding
this process what did you all observe
that you tell other people here's what
you do if you're going to get out of
debt you got to do these three things or
these four things what what was the
thing you think of I think one of the
big things first off is just
communication especially coming from two
different financial backgrounds and what
that look like and saying okay we're a
couple now God said we're one so we got
to figure out how we can do that to
start off so definitely starting off
communication and then coming up with
the plan and then figuring out exactly
what we need to do with that plan and
what that step is going to take and
making sacrifices so even though I was
working as a personal trainer still have
been you know you know I worked at
Chick-fil-A for a little bit to earn a
little extra income on top of that in
the evenings and then uh before we got
married paying off even car loan debt
and stuff like that too and then going
from there and like okay like if we're
going to attack this we're going to
attack this and get it paid off cuz most
people my age most friends are not in
this position being in their 20s so we
wanted to glorify God along the way but
understand like we don't have to just be
in debt and that's not the not the right
way to do things not the plan you had to
feel like when the student loans started
back with payments the the day that you
dodged a bullet absolutely we did we
were like watching it while we were
paying it off and they like okay they
pushed it back more okay we got to go
before they put interest like we got to
keep paying it and like I think that was
the one good thing about the co year
honestly yeah we're like thank you for
that because I remember I submitted my
first payment was $150 and then by the
time we got married I was like oh we got
huge payments here and then yeah about
in April we're like oh we're debt free
and it it felt weird it was but it was
great we're like what the heck yeah just
like that boom yeah wow I love it if you
want something different you have to do
something different and you guys
embraced that it was it's different
right to give back some of your marriage
money it's different for one spouse when
they're you know engaged to say you know
when we get married some of my savings
is going to go to pay off this debt like
that that's all completely different
from what culture might say you know to
work a second job in the evenings
Chick-fil-A in the evenings so you guys
really did sacrifice to win that's
amazing yep well done it proud of you
thank you I'm betting both sets of
parents were bragging on you the whole
way you on yeah oh yeah that's great
couple of financial peace babies one
more intense than the other but there we
go I love it still very good good job
you guys very well done your future I
mean when you you can take any problem
and set it in front of you too and you
do exactly what you did here you analyze
the problem and say what must be true
what have we got to do to get this done
all right lean in next thing you know
game on and you'll have these things pop
up from time to time hopefully this one
will never pop up again but uh but
you'll have other things as you go
through your life and now you're
equipped so so that's the gift I mean
the getting out of debt is powerful but
the process that you use is even more
powerful yeah so working together having
a plan thank you to the every dollar app
people well done well done good here's
my budget look at it I like that I
sounded like that I did it the bestt
very good we've got the live and give
box for you that's the baby steps
millionaire book which is your next step
on the journey to be able to live and
give like no one else and then of course
The Total Money Makeover you can give
that to someone else get them started
Financial Peace University if you hadn't
gone through it go through it together
if you have give it to somebody and uh
that's why we call it live and give so
enjoy well done you guys congratulations
Heroes you're Heroes man that's powerful
Joshua and Becca Indianapolis Indiana
50,000 paid off in 7 months been married
12 months did it making
83,000 count it down let's hear a debt
free Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
free
W that's how that's
done I love
it man oh man if everybody could get it
that quick Dave it'd be so much easier
oh gosh yeah yeah that's uh but that's
the good news about being second
generation Financial Peace you know
Financial Peace babies it's even if you
got a if you're a little off you still
can you boom you hit it you know you
know if you hit it it'll work it's like
um yeah that's that's different hey
you're doing an every dollar webinar
tomorrow Tuesday at 11:30 that's right
for those of you listening totally free
that is the 20th uh no it's not it's the
10th the 10th tomorrow at uh at 11:30
central time we're going to be doing a
few others if you want to join the free
every dooll webinar on how to do just
what he did I did a budget so you'll be
able to do it tomorrow right that's
right and everydollar.com budgeting sign
up with Jade for tomorrow or uh Jade
later or Rachel Cruz or George camel
we're doing them all through through the
fall here you're going to want to sign
up and be part of that just like he did
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Romans 13:1 let
every person be subject to the governing
authorities for there is no Authority
except from God and those that exist
have been instituted by God Milton
Freedman said if you put the federal
government in charge of the Sahara
desert in 5 years there'd be a shortage
of sand oh
gosh
sheesh Nobel prize winning Economist by
the
way oh you got to love it Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
uh we are in the last day of Dr John
delon's Book Week launch uh we launched
it one week ago tomorrow his new book is
called building a non anxious life and
it is the six daily habits uh that are
needed to do that to deal with anxiety
to prepare for when anxious things
happen your glass is full and you can
deal with them and uh this is uh this is
a lot of Neuroscience a lot of nerd
speak all boiled down where normal
people can read it like me and uh Dr
John this is his second book his first
was a number one National
bestseller um own your past change your
future building a non-anxious life has
already sold a bazillion copies in uh
the pre-sale and in the first week thank
you guys for the response to this we'll
know for sure where we land on the list
in a day or two but pretty much uh
suspect it'll be number one based on our
based on our sales um and normal normal
book business stuff but we'll see we'll
see we've sold a bunch of them and you
guys are we appreciate you thank you for
picking it up that you're going to be
glad you did it's worth every penny it's
a great book ramsy solutions.com you can
get it there you can get it anywhere
great books are sold Amazon Barnes &
Noble all of that building a non-anxious
Life by Dr John deloney Britney's in
Phoenix hi Britney welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you so much Dave sure what's
up so my husband and I are wondering if
we should sell our investment property
to pay off of our debt all of our debt
okay uh do you like the investment
property love it
but we have a kid on the way and so
things are changing for us um and our
income is going to significantly drop
you're going to stay
home okay your your phone's breaking up
like crazy um having trouble see if you
can get somewhere where we can hear you
but anyway so what do you
make um that we make about 125 125 what
do you make
yes I make uh 75 of that okay okay
what's the investment property
worth uh 200,000 and we take home uh we
net $1300 each month on it what does it
what do you owe on
it um
we what do you owe on
it it's free and clear we don't owe
anything oh okay and what is your your
personal residence mortgage is how much
uh 345 currently okay and you you have
145,000 other than
this um I'm sorry I I didn't okay you
have 200 if you sell the rental you owe
345 you said pay off your house yeah do
you have other money
saved uh no we do not we be paying off
our uh some of our other Consumer Debt
student loans and medical bills that's
$82
000 so um we would were hoping to that
and
then where did this uh where did this
rental property come from how'd you end
up with a paid for $200,000 house if
you're this
broke so um we actually we wrapped it
into the financing of our our home
oh so our primary residence is worth
$500,000 and and this invested property
is worth
$200,000 so we've
got mortgage and then $82,000 of other
debt and we're wanting to sell the
investment to pay um these the Deb
consum loans and medical yes I would
sell
it yeah yeah I would sell it um you pay
off 82,000 in Consumer Debt you got a
baby on the way you a $345,000 mortgage
you're getting ready to be making
$50,000 a year I'm not sure how you're
paying for a $345,000 mortgage you may
be selling your home too that's what I'm
thinking um I don't think you can
service at thatt on 50 Grand unless they
I'm not sure about it but unless they
sold their existing house and moved into
the rental and then had that one free
and clear might go that way yeah because
I don't think you can I mean if if you
quit you make 75 of the 125 he's got
he's got $50,000 income paying a pay
payment on yeah that's going to your
payment's got to be four grand
anyway and yeah you're not going to make
that your payment's going to be as much
as his income MH yeah that's not going
to work H they got to get out of their
existing home you can't keep the house M
you can't afford it so yeah we're
selling the wrong
house uh you're moving into the paid for
rental the good news is oring paid for
or you're working yeah you got to decide
but if you want to keep this house the
one you live in you're working
and you sell the rental and payoff if
you if you're working you sell the
rental and pay off all the other dayb
you can probably make it it's tight then
yeah but um but you can't make it you
can't pay the payments on this and you
pay down a little bit on the 345 and
redo the loan at a higher interest rate
you're not going to you're not going to
net anything different so there's
nothing happening here kid I'm sorry
yeah that that the house you bought you
can't afford if you want to quit and
stay home with a baby and either one's
an okay Choice with me mhm uh personally
I'd move into the rental and stay home
because that's your that's your heart's
desire exactly I'd rather stay home than
have the house the big house MH uh the
house you can't afford but you can't pay
the payments on his income and if they
are living in the $200,000 house paid
for their income's freed up they can
start stacking away money they're 100%
free yeah there's more freedom there you
get to stay home you have no debt that
would be my that'd be my solution you
start you know you start stacking cash
and then if you want to move up in house
in a few years you'll be able to do that
with cash but you cannot afford a
payment on 345,000 making 50 Grand I'm
100% sure of that M and there's not not
any numbers you gave me here unless
there's a piece that Britney didn't give
me yeah that uh that changed that if
there's a $200,000 laying somewhere else
but I didn't hear that you did ask that
because you said when she wanted to pay
off the debt for the the their existing
home you said do you have another 145
she said no so you have it no we have
another 82 and consumer was our answer
yeah that's it Jay's in Tampa hey Jay
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave and Jay can you guys hear
me okay you can yes better thank you how
can we help thanks thanks for taking my
call okay so I I just I'm gonna hit you
with some numbers um I the main question
is uh I want to know if we should use
the check that we're expecting from the
car insurance I just got into a car AC a
few days ago and you're get did you
total
it yes did you owe money on it
no free and clear we just paid it off
okay what's it
worth uh it's worth between 9 and 11 buy
another car with
it rather than yes because I was gonna
use it towards the IRS because they're
breeding down my throats right now that
could be different yeah that does change
what do you owe the KGB
for well uh before my wife and I got
married um how much is the
balance 91 almost 9200 and you got
another car 9200 I have another car we
make 140 a year we pay it off pay it off
and save two months and get you a
different car MH pay off the IRS and
then save like crazy get R get those
people out of your life yeah I until you
said that until you said that I was real
sure yeah like Jade said that's a game
changer okay I thought so what I'm
squeez in one more question how do you I
know you normally say stop all 401K
contributions too I what if you can use
the 401K contributions to break even on
your taxes no no no no you don't break
even on your taxes that's not how taxes
work you don't break even tax deductions
you save a quarter on the dollar you
don't break even you put in $100 it
saves you $25 on taxes you're broke you
can't do that you need to get the
stinking IRS paid off pile up some cash
get the emergency fund billt make sure
you get you another car purchase get all
the debts cleared then build your
emergency fund well you got one out of
two not bad all right not bad Jade good
show today good show of the team in the
booth excellent excellent calls coming
in that puts us hour the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's Ramy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter